this is the F-16 fighter jet developed
by the US with a number of European
partners
and this is the su-35 the Russian
equivalent being deployed in the Ukraine
war
Kiev says at once 200 Western Jets such
as the eurofighter typhoon F-16 or
Swedish Griffin so it can dominate the
skies we have freedom give us Wings to
protect it
and while the US has said it won't give
fighter jets to Kiev the UK and some
European countries are now considering
sending combat aircraft
any decision to send or to supply combat
aircraft
would inevitably be significant so what
capabilities could Western Jets give
Ukraine and how do they compare to the
main Russian jet deployed in the war
first let's look at why Western jets are
important to Kiev
so far neither Ukraine nor Russia has
achieved air superiority that's an Air
Force's ability to take control of the
sky stopping anybody other than
themselves from entering a particular
airspace at the start of the war Moscow
had nearly 1200 combat capable aircraft
according to the iiss think tank that
was far more than kiev's inventory of
around 120 aging soviet-era aircraft so
the challenge for Ukraine is its
combative inventory is increasingly
difficult to maintain in a combat
environment you really need as many of
your aircraft available and on the
flight line as you can have almost
Around the Clock
to avoid using their limited Jets
Ukraine has focused on its air defenses
shooting down over 100 Russian planes
and helicopters with surface-to-way
missiles this has made Moscow reluctant
to send its own Jets beyond the front
line analysts say it's mainly used the
long-range capabilities of its Air Force
to strike Ukrainian targets from afar so
one of the challenges the ukrainians
have is that the Soviet era missiles
particularly the Beyond visual range
weapons
don't of anything like the engagement
range that the Russian combat aircraft
do at the moment
experts say Western jets would allow
Kiev to counter Russia's Air Force
directly changing the balance of power
in the skies
so let's look at the specifics of how
these Jets operate on the battlefield
Russia's su-35 is larger than the
aircraft Ukraine could receive from its
allies allowing it to carry a bigger
weapons payload it's also equipped with
a passive sensor that can spot opposing
Jets without being detected itself
paired with long-range missiles that can
fire at Targets over 60 miles away
analysts say it's had a distinct
advantage in medium and long range
aerial encounters against Ukraine's
current inventory of Soviet era aircraft
but Western Jets such as the F-16 would
come equipped with Advanced medium-range
missiles including the American AI m120
analysts say these weapons could level
the playing field allowing Ukraine to
more effectively challenge Russia's Air
Force in medium and long-range
encounters
but when it comes to air power it's not
just the systems that matter the person
piloting the jet is just as important
experts say Ukraine's Pilots will need
extensive training for up to a year to
use any Western aircraft effectively you
can't just take somebody out of a Soviet
designed combat aircraft and expect them
to be able to fight to the same level
the next day even when I'm experienced
fast yet pilot there is a period of
conversions and just to get used to the
aircraft is displays how it handles and
then you also got to learn how to fight
the aircraft
so the UK has agreed to start training
Ukrainian Pilots as Kiev continues to
press its allies into providing Jets
Western governments are nervous that
providing the weapons which could be
used to hit targets inside Russia could
escalate the war
but analysts say that any model of jet
would complement the Arsenal or Weaponry
including High Mars and tanks but Kiev
is already receiving from its allies
foreign